i'm set up here uh jj it's it's time bud
it's it's time it's time
it's jj time dave's not here man
oh that's a good joke dude did you come
up with that yeah
it's really good can you see the screen
yep
perfect um
male head huh a good old male hey
kitty's put together this perfect when
we finally get introduced
go ahead i'm gonna say something right
now you need to go a couple videos back
that's a little bit ahead of where we're
at oh okay
that's fair all right let me see here
[Music]
oh because she needs to go through how
she lost it because that's the fun part
which one is it here
uh gods you make so many videos
yeah dude it's a [ __ ] machine yeah
strange things happening
uh two rows up there you go right there
i think it's either that one
yeah that one so
okay i got it we'll have that one so you
by the way kitty puts
put together this [ __ ] she did a lot
of work from when we finally introduced
and it's gonna be soon introduce her to
the rotc universe she's like she gave me
time stamps and clips i mean i am ready
for this
it's gonna be glorious um
so the tale of old mayo head
which you know some people that watch
this i'll say this they're like oh
you're being so mean why are you being
so mean
there's a lot of people that know this
person that say she's a terrible person
and that she's a liar like
personally know her that i have a
message in me saying thank god you guys
are doing this
she's terrible she does terrible things
whether it's true or not i don't know
but i just want to let everybody know
that that's something that people have
been messaging me
and i'm not talking about like our fans
[ __ ] trolling i'm talking about
actual people than that
i don't know what you call it there's a
whole like subset of people that [ __ ]
with us before or [ __ ] with her before
we even got
to her so she's well aware that there
are people that
go around the internet and make fun of
people okay so
what all right this one like notice how
discolored her neck is because she wore
that necklace for so damn long
hey jj why would she take the necklace
off what could have happened
i don't know uh maybe it was internet
ridicule
maybe it was someone trying to i don't
know she goes a lot of places with
things
well i guess we're good you know what i
guess we're gonna find out aren't we
okay um i don't know exactly what's
going on
but i think that somebody was in my
apartment
again again again
i told you it's a machine dude if you if
you don't pay attention to her for one
day you're gonna miss it holy [ __ ]
her chest is so tan and her neck is so
light
while i was gone today um
about two o'clock i left to go and take
some recycling in
and at least she's environmentally
conscious which i think is very
important
it has nothing to do with making hobo
cash uh does anybody know of her
controller's okay
i think it is okay good i was worried
then i rode the bus down to the
dispensary to grab um
a gram of popcorn so
i haven't been here for a little bit i
just got back
and i noticed now so here's a question i
have jj
obviously you know you smoke a lot of
weed yes
and uh i used to i don't anymore but i i
stopped like a year ago
more than you will enough it happens
it's like it's cyclical
if if i come down there you're smoking
weed no i'll tell you this right now i
will make you a solemn promise
that i haven't smoked weed since last
year in december like 2019
right i will break that if you come down
i will get high with you i promise i
will
bring you the finest that virginia has
to offer so i will
absolutely do that but um
but here's here's a question i have
because you you are the weed guy
if you were homeless right and you were
getting money from the government to
live
would you still spend it on weed no i
would i would hustle the weed
you know what i mean it's called
hustling you you know you know
you know what the correct thing to do is
when you're in that situation
you would sell weed yeah that's well
that's the key you sell the weed and
then you have some for yourself
that way you get the weed for free see
you get the point now
yes just that the front door
uh i have there's two locks right
there's the there's the top
bolt and then there's lock on the door
door i don't
lock the door i only lock the deadbolt
because i don't see a reason to lock the
door
if the deadbolt is locked now here's
what i'm thinking if they got through
the dead ball jj
it's clearly a mission impossible
situation
or they had the key
oh [ __ ] dude
like because i don't know about you but
the first the first thing i do when i
move in someplace is i change the lock
so i don't know
of course of course that's some people
don't do that that's [ __ ] the first
and you move into a new place it's cheap
you change the [ __ ] locks
always well all right i i'll i'm lying
here because when i moved in the place
i'm at here i had to change the lock
code because it's one of them fancy
doors with the code thingy on it
but i still change code to change the
code did the same thing exchange the key
so when i got back
i unlocked the dead bolt and turned the
knob and the
the knob was locked i was like that's
kind of strange why did wha
when why did i lock the door could it be
that you just forgot
could it be that you're just making this
up
are you implying that this woman's a
liar jj
um she's a fibber okay fiber tall you
know what
talty tall tales
tall tales a liar would actually do like
a liar lies
to cover something important up a fiber
makes things up just to [ __ ] be fibs
ah like like my brother yeah
is he good i haven't heard from him in a
while [ __ ] you tell me
i don't know is the wife still crazy
she's running for congress
i always thought she did that's all my
life deadbolt but i never lock the hand
the door hand knob so
i i looked around and i didn't think
there was anything missing
right my controller is right here thank
god
wow still there [ __ ] i think that was
what i
i would have i was losing sleep wanting
if controller was here my
yarn my pieces no no no no
own bb truth's got a really good point i
don't even think about this remember roy
she said if anything was stolen from her
place
you'd buy her new stuff she's waiting on
you royce
hey hold that thought all right we got a
couple videos from now all right hold
that thought all right do me a favor
while while
can somebody go to shitty necklaces.com
cause this big i'm fine i've got the
stupid hobo live yes
seriously and
then i went to like um make myself a new
necklace
and i can't find my pendant
and i'm like why would they steal my
necklace pendant but not steal
the tv or the game controller
yeah that's kind of weird right
um i don't have an answer to that
usually i'm an answer guy but i don't i
don't know why
it's kind of [ __ ] weird right just a
tad yeah it's a little suspicious just a
little sus
that that doesn't make sense but at the
same
where else is it like it could be a
butthole i don't know i wonder what's
inside there did you check the piles of
[ __ ] in the bathroom
is it in there is it in the ceiling dust
yeah it fits into the [ __ ] ceiling
dust
hey did you feed it to one of the ducks
it's on the table like i've got my oh my
god is that her setup hold on let me go
back here
i gotta see this stuff hey guys rate her
setup
uh negative hobo is that let me
you think that's an i9 processor wonder
what her gpu is
i'm just saying man you could take you
could you could put a homeless
hobo in a house but you can't take the
homeless hobo out of the homeless hobo
mm-hmm you could lead a hobo to water
but you can't make it not murder ducks
bingo like i've got my little
table don't judge that that's a box
that's not a table that's a yes exactly
it's an amazon box
that's a microwave box what's okay but
let's see what's on the table we got
scissors
uh-huh what is the thing next to it
looks like yarn and a [ __ ]
pile of pink i guess i don't know yeah
top left that that's a
that's one of the wheat prescription
weed things that the the weed comes in
that i know
uh that's her prescription pill bottle
for her hoo-hoo
uh pills oh yeah guessing the tupperware
back there is where she breaks her weed
up at
watch i'm gonna start a fight i and by
the way maureen she told me she goes i
i i crochet better than maureen does she
told
i'm i'm not trying to start anything so
i can hit the air horn
oh yeah i don't have that on my board
but uh for a discord we would yeah we
will but we're not
but we're not i know and you know
i could easily use this crew because i
use it every night to play valheim it's
like i can't use it well aware
it's just you just do this like bali
tortures me with jib jabs i know
it's okay look i understand bali
tortures you with jib jabs but he
tortures me with [ __ ] [ __ ]
well he's not even the first one a
rational meanie he's been doing it for
months now like i don't get it why
everybody wants to fight with me
and his lovely assistant they've all
been being mean nice guy yeah
so nice they call you nice guy stoner
and i don't know why they're being so
mean to you
let's go back to her [ __ ] nightstand
um right here okay what else do we got
up here we go
there's the real prescription bottle a
lighter but she's using the [ __ ] the
don't if you're gonna buy one of these
shitty [ __ ] gas station lighters
don't buy a lighter buy a bic or [ __ ]
beat it
yeah like i hate these those stupid
disposable
clear plastic [ __ ] lighters i mean
the only thing
worse is if she had like a zippo or
something was trying to light her bowl
with that
hey maybe she could knit herself a job
next to my bed and it was on
i think she's knitting it's on the table
oh that box is from target it's not even
amazon
i'm betting it's a microwave you're
probably right
it was right here i took it off i put it
here
so can i also point out that uh
forks and and butter knives go in the
kitchen not in your [ __ ]
nightside table box that is her that is
her kitchen
dude all right never mind that's the
island that she has in her kitchen
hey glaucoma california weed does need
uh
broken up you'll see later again i'm not
trying to spoil anything later but okay
yeah i've looked around my room i've
looked around the house
and it's not i'm not finding it
so um i'm gonna have to go down to skid
row tomorrow and buy myself a new
pendant
and uh why why do you need it you're
homeless
right money no no i understand that
whatever
why you need that if you're homeless
like
you you wouldn't be buying garbage
and then and that that these plucking
pendants are the definition of garbage
um i i think something did happen while
i was gone because
just after i got back maintenance
knocked on the door and they gave me a
new key
so maintenance walked in so let me get
this straight
because the thing is i always like to
figure this out
maintenance walked in and they decided
when they walked into your palatial
apartment they decided i'm not gonna
steal the
[ __ ] i'm assuming one of those like
off-brand tvs like a kobe
tv i am not going to steal your
controller i'm not going to steal your
yarn
or not even the real wheat exactly the
first thing you takes the weed right
i'm not going to steal any or your
prescription pills yeah
i'm natural yeah so i'm not going to
take any of those things
i'm not even going to take the whole
necklace i'm just gonna take the pendant
yes just the pendant huh
um they said that they had changed the
locks
on the front of the the front
um but that was like i don't know i've
kind of been expecting them to do
do that because when i moved in the
front door didn't
they told me they were gonna have to
replace the locks because it was broken
so
it was just it's strange that they came
right after i got back to give me that
key
and it's even stranger that i've i've
misplaced my pendant
um because this isn't a big it's not a
big apartment where the hell
what what where did i lose it you know
i mean you haven't taken it off for like
nine months yeah it probably just fell
off because of rot
so many places i could have placed it
and it really doesn't make sense that
they would have stole the pendant and
not stolen the tv
so um well the pendant you could put in
your pocket the tv is going to be a
little bit harder to notice in broad
daylight that's a good point
i'm paranoid this is [ __ ] this is why
having mental and mental health issues
suck because like
there's a part of my brain that is
logically saying nobody came into your
apartment and took your [ __ ] necklace
pendant that cost a dollar
and left you overpaid dollar
the 50 game boy controller there but
then there's this other part that's
saying
they would do it just to [ __ ] with you
who
is they uh
the juice oh okay well i mean i get it
but even what even why would they want
that
i mean dude they they they want
everything all right good point fair
enough
just like the people online are [ __ ]
with you there's people that just [ __ ]
with who
who online is [ __ ] oh
i forgot
so i don't i don't i don't know
no she does she's tired of getting
picked on about her stupid pendant so
she had to go get a new one to prove
that she had changed it
that's my theory i believe you because
she didn't want to
she don't want to think that us poking
fun in it
is the reason she did no she wouldn't
admit that anyways
me that i can't find my damn pendant
when there's it should be
right there on the table michael's right
maybe their pendant was one of the
infinity stones and someone came in to
steal it
oh [ __ ] man is that how vision died has
somebody has somebody asked thanos
did wanda bring her back is that why she
has another one already
why why would wanda bring a [ __ ]
homeless person into west view
you [ __ ] kidding me like
how far can it get
and that's that she puts a joke at the
end of it i
she does random jokes and random things
she likes to
change it up a bit every once in a while
what is she a [ __ ] popsicle
yeah something like that is this the
next one new necklace
no that's not the next one there are
holy [ __ ] how many
things does this hooker make serious if
you miss one day of this [ __ ] you're
going to be behind
uh yeah did i black out this is the next
one
up next row there we go i am
tripping um i like
nice it completely cleaned up the room
i moved the um box
i looked under the bed around the bed
the blankets
that pendant is gone okay
how and why
how because you threw it away why
because you were being made fun of for
wearing it for 60 years
because we necklace shamed you mm-hmm
you're i believe the tournament we're
gaslighting jj
yes that's the term we're being real big
gaslighters
they repeat a bunch of gas holes
i mean if somebody took it
uh why when there's a tv
right there there's a microwave in the
living room that's still in the box
um all right so i guess i was wrong that
was not the microwave box answered that
question i was worried about okay now we
know
now we know there are people that keep
score at home jj so it's important we
let them know
oh i know because if not if you're wrong
they'll write like 18 page [ __ ] blog
talk radio about it
that's what we need to do we need to get
her to you know what we need to do
let's all leave youtube and let's all go
back to block talk what do you think
yes blog test radio all aisle in with
our phones
and sound like ass it'll be great
maybe it'll get [ __ ] coletta to come
out of hiding
well i mean have you have you heard the
reason why he's not around
no but tell me offline i'm curious it's
i don't know who but there's a reason
well then i please let me know
you're you're more connected uh to that
friend more than that friends connected
to me but i will oh
really yeah oh i'm so curious
shoot me shoot me a message just shoot
me a message right now
just sue me a quick message on discord
so obviously that makes absolutely no
sense
but the necklace is most definitely gone
so something happened right
um did i dissociate
hold on a second does she have d.i.d now
oh you know multiple personalities
sometimes it happens
i don't know i i
i hope not i'm um
i used to do that when things were
really bad like
when i was first married
is that the guy that gave her hiv or
almost gave her hiv
dude i've mixed them up so much it
probably is the hiv guy but then there's
a she's been married twice i think so it
could be the other one that just raped a
beater
i'm not sure so you're telling me two
people decided that this body needed to
be locked down
i guess i don't know i don't i [ __ ]
the story up a lot because she changes
it so god damn much
no [ __ ] i would literally go weeks
um just on autopilot
uh and have no memory of what what i did
what okay i'm sorry i'm br
you know man i've been trying to keep up
with this and obviously you know the
lore a little better than me and i know
you're all
even you are still confused yeah but
because it's difficult so
let me get this straight okay
she used to live with her grandma her
grandma passed away
mima her meemaw passed away she had to
live on her own
she she's from florida originally she
became homeless
she married one of the two dudes that
she married had hiv but she took
medicine to prevent her from getting hiv
she didn't shower for three months when
she finally got a place with a shower
there was [ __ ] in it
human or dog we don't not really sure i
think you're you're missing the time
that she was in
her truck homeless there was a time
where she got some bought her a truck
and there's a time that she was in that
before she got to the the [ __ ] uh i
guess that was a hobo
hotel okay she was she was no mad salmon
pretty much yes okay so then she did
that and then she moved into whatever
this
she got government money oh no wait back
up a little bit with her trump box
she used it to give a hundred dollars to
and by the way the merkel the megan
merkel
is not the german one someone corrected
me
it's one of the royal family people the
one that got married to one of the dudes
yeah she lives in canada now right she
lives in canada
um i think she's roommates with frozen
asian
and she so so that so she gave that
money away
she moved to a place she allegedly
murdered ducks by feeding them rice
um she is gonna become a game streamer
by streaming um earthbound
can i just say something right off the
bat you're gonna have to condense this
a whole lot for merch to understand oh i
know i know
i i i'm working on and i i'm trying to
get this as
as easily digestible as possible
streamlined it's a lot it's a lot
yeah so it's possible what i'm thinking
of that's why it's so good though what
i'm thinking of doing in rotc is
so we're going to do like you know those
movies where like they start you like in
the middle and then they flash back
i'm going to start with the mayo head
and go like
you know to kind of like that's going to
hook them in right if i do the
do the mail head we're going to hook
them in and then we're going to go back
and do the lure
yeah and then hit them with the uh phil
and selmo area start at the
beginning we'll we'll do a two week
we'll do it like a one year
earlier you know well
two hobo towns after as far back as i
can remember i always wanted to be a
hobo
[Laughter]
that i just i had a blackout and
but what would i have done with it if i
don't know man
you're the crazy one who are you asking
um put it off camera just
maybe just come on if i had
even if i had blacked out like
there's only so many places i could move
it to
i don't have anything i'm using boxes as
tables like where am i going to hide it
i have no food
under the box um what's in the box
who's in the chair yes
[Laughter]
yeah there's a throwback what's
happening yay
crap
this is a long way to go to convince two
fat guys that you didn't
get necklace it is a lot of work because
i don't know about you but once i end
this show i don't care anymore
no none of this matters to me
if i had a blackout
well i'll take that back a couple hours
later i'll take a [ __ ] and look through
youtube and then it'll be like oh look
what i'm doing tomorrow
you know what reminds you because you're
taking his [ __ ] and reminds you the [ __ ]
in her shower i get it
exactly and then i think of bali and
then i [ __ ] more it's pavlov [ __ ]
what do i do because
the last time i was having them i wasn't
seeing a doctor or a therapist or
anything it was just like
my husband would be like oh you're back
you know um because i'm sorry is she
trying to pull the walter white thing
when he just woke up like when he was
the naked in the grocery store
yeah except when she was away she was
making necklaces
ah instead of meth yes meth is more
profitable lady
and she wasn't in an rv she was in a box
noticeable change so like
it was something that he knew was
happening to me
but i had no idea all right can i
address something
sure uh sinister charlie said get a job
first off she can't even keep up with a
pendant you expect her to flip a burger
[ __ ] off
i want her on disability and the [ __ ]
away from doing things all right can we
get that straight
with the job anywhere anyway we don't
even we don't live in california it's
their shitty money not ours
but no there's 15 of these stupid [ __ ]
in every single [ __ ] city so that's a
good point
you know until he told me
that doesn't make sense um i only know
because there was a game
remember like before wwe had divas they
uh like japan had the female wrestlers
and they were all ugly because they were
good she looks like she looks like a new
japan wrestler
a little bit what's that one
uh [ __ ] forgot her name
the one that does the punk rock bit oh
yeah yeah ruby riot
yeah that one yeah it kind of looks like
a scuffed version of ruby right yeah
that he bought me this game
it was either for my birthday or for
christmas yeah the game was called
lithium and he told you to
play it every day and i picked it up
and i started playing it and i was
really good at it right away and i was
like wow
this game is either really easy or i'm
really good at it
and he said well she's a natural talent
she's a natural out of the way jj she's
a real gamer
it's it's the man's shoulders and man
jaw you know what you should do i have
an idea jj
hear me out here we invite her to the
valheim server but we make her live
outside of the fortress in attendance
like we'll build just a little dog house
we'll call it the [ __ ] hood
hey bally can you build the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but you should be you played it for a
full week when we borrowed it from my
buddy
i still remember it's kelly slater
surfing
um i had no
memory of playing that game but
part of my mind remembered it because i
was able to play it again immediately
you know um she can probably go on to
the next veggie if you want i think
she's gonna babble for another two more
minutes